George this is this is crazy you have
over 33 years how you've built up a lab
the church lab and your lab has a
hundred people now that how is this how
do you possibly figure out how to manage
this this is this is important because
we have now we're moving into these labs
at Boyden has a really popular now lab
we have more of these labs sort of
popping up with these really roaring
groups of scientists and engineers
intellectuals pushing the boundaries of
knowledge and we want to know how to
best design the the frameworks and the
flows of information in these labs so
you know maybe we start off by asking
you you know here you are running this
lab how do you pick what research and
how do you delegate research to other
people yeah well a lot of this has to do
with Co mentoring so I co mentor with ed
Boyden and Bob Langer and Sangeeta
Bhatia we help each other out because
we're running kind of similar kinds of
labs and there's commitment within the
lab you don't necessarily need a big
hierarchy if you've got a good will I
select for people that are nice and
that's one of my you know first
interview questions is or discussions is
how you achieve that kind of environment
you you want to have an environment
where failure is an option but fail fast
if you get on to the next thing to a
bunch of things in parallel it's like
the lesson of biology is not to make one
prototype but a trillion prototypes was
hard to do a trillion projects but you
can at least do more than one you know
have a kind of a real group size of
about three so so the hundreds is just a
group a bunch of groups of three okay
have interdisciplinary teams so it's
hard to make an ax dissipate team out of
disciplinarians so it's easier to make
it out of people that are themselves
interdisciplinary so you have like two
people that know
two different languages even if there's
no overlap of any of those like they
they know how to gain a third one still
each gain a third one that's a shared
language and then they can and they
could build up this network of people
that are just then you can decorate it
with a few disciplinarians at the end
but the major network of know-how I
think has to be people who feel
comfortable with two or more fields in
their own head and this is like
molecular biology and computer science
maybe something like you know or you
know philosophy of ethics and and and
medicine or you know optics and genetics
virtus ya know the three-dimensional
structure of the genome and etc there's
and once you get used to it then it
becomes it becomes you know good at
whatever you do and if you have a lab
that does it are just learning stuff and
does entrepreneurship and does and
really generally has its sights on
transformative technology then something
that seems like science fiction becomes
more routine because that's what you do
every day is you transform things that
look hard you know things they're
actually easy you don't want to be
actual heroes you just want to find the
low-hanging fruit and and help everybody
get